مره اخرى ينزل اهالي اسفاقس ولسانه حالهم
يقول اسفاقس تستغيث بعد ما غرقت في
النفايات واختنقت جراء احراق عدد كبير
بالالاف الاطنان من هذه النفايات في احد
المكبات وسط المدينه في الوقت الاحتجاجيه
اليوم عام شهرين والزبله نزلت من كاس عام
شهرين والاحلى تعبنا تعبنا للامانه
في حاله رئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس حكومه حاله
ايش تقصير على خاطر سيد وصلنا لعدم حاجه
كبيره القلب
[تصفيق]
هذه هي الازمه التي جاوزت السنه لا يمكن
تعاطي معها الا بالرفع الفوري للفضلات
المتراكمه وتعاطي معها ايضا بحلول اجله
عبر تسمين هذه النفايات هكذا تحدث منظم
هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه حول
المركزي خضر هنا في سباق والا يمكن ما
يحبش معنا بس يطلعوا في تحركات على
المستوى العاصمه همم على ملك الوصل
يعتبرنا مواطنين كامل الحقوق والواجبات
واقف انتظار هي رفع الاف نادي التي تقدست
في مختلف ارجاء المدينه مع تواصل اغلاق
مكباتها الرئيسيه يهدد الاهالي ومنظمات
المجتمع المدنيه باتخافي خطوات تصعيديه
اكبر وذلك بالتوجه في يوم غضب الى العاصمه
مع التهديد بمقاطعه الانتخابات التشريعيه
القادمه من وسط مدينه صفاقس لقناتي
العربيه والحدث والاد عبد الله تونس